a high-stakes week-long competition ends
tonight in Alaska and the contestants
don't even know they're competing a
brown bear in Alaska as Katmai National
Park will soon be named the winner of
fat bear week that's right
fat bear week fans are voting in an
online contest for the bear that's done
the best job packing on the pounds
before hibernation CBS Sunday mornings
Lea Cowen gives us the skinny on
nature's battle for the heavyweight
crown in a world where a honey badger
once got his own viral video seems only
natural that the brown bears of Alaska
finally get their own fat competition
something to celebrate
Andrew LaValle is a park ranger at
Katmai National Park a remote place even
by Alaska standards chances are you will
never visit here but bear cams can bring
the Bears to you and one thing
impossible to ignore is how they pack on
the pounds before hibernation most start
the season looking like this but end it
somewhere in the middle of all those
furry roles for the food long winters
nap doesn't include GrubHub deliveries a
battle with nervous eating that the
National Park Service thought could be
educational and fun thanks to likes on
their Facebook page that's how fat bear
week was born four years ago complete
with a march madness style bracket this
year two-time reigning champion ODIs
looked to be the heavy favorite but last
Friday lost out to Rollie pollie bead
nose that prompted one fat bear fan to
write Otis is getting robbed
because bead nose looks so cozily rotund
in a sitting position is there no
justice here we know how notice is
taking his loss chunk seen here in the
spring powered through some 30 salmon a
day gaining 4 pounds a day to get to a
sleeping weight of about half a ton but
that wasn't enough to out fish the bear
known as 747 is now flying into the
championship matchup against big nose
7:47 is aptly named one post read just
look at that wide body we see these
faint bears day-in day-out it's kind of
old news for us some days but to see
people from around the world
however a affinity for these wild
creatures is pretty amazing
the final vote comes tonight Fat Tuesday
as it were but the paparazzi are out of
luck the victor will likely be somewhere
far away sleeping it off blissfully
unaware of their newfound bat Fame for
CBS this morning we count well Sam Lee
Cowan I like I like a contest where you
win for gaining weight yeah I don't
Weight Watchers up there and all watches
zero night tonight right we find out
yeah tonight we can tell you tomorrow